Let's go now to part two of our study of how
the Trump, Ian Fox news propaganda cycles
work. This next story is a story that in a
normal world on a normal planet would not
be a story, but in the story of Donald Trump's
2019 reality, this is a very real story. Fox
and friends has been caught editing out and
minimizing the booing and the chanting of
lock 'em up that took place during Donald
Trump's brief appearance at game five of the
world series, uh, over the weekend. So to
remind you, yesterday I played for you a bunch
of clips of Trump showing up in Washington,
D C for game five of the world series and
the entire place booing him as soon as he
appeared on screen chanting lock 'em up and
Trump visibly grimacing when he realized that
that that's what takes, that's what's taking
place. The real world is not the, uh, echo
chamber filter bubble of his carefully curated
rallies that he's been doing. We talked about
that yesterday. Here's Fox and friends yesterday
with the booing, notably missing a, I'm going
to do audio only here because a, there is
footage in this video of um, the uh, of, of
copywritten content. Major league baseball
is extraordinarily aggressive. So I'm just
going to be doing audio here. Let's take a
very quick listen to this
because the president and first lady were
at the game last night. They got there right
around the time that it started and they stayed
a pretty long time. They were greeted with
MIS, mixed reaction, but they were out there
smiling, waving to everybody as you can see
in the crowd. So that's what happened right
around game time. Let's say it get to the
top of the second ending right now and show
you some of that action. Alvarez has a two
run home. Run that.
Yeah, so then they just get into highlights
from the game. It was all great fun. And I
love how she calls it. Mixed reaction, which
might be true only in the most technical sense,
but this was a crowd that was very hostile
to the president of the United States. They
did not want Donald Trump there. That is the
sort of bigger truth that Fox and friends
can't or won't tell their audience. Reminder,
this is what was going on yesterday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and then of course the chance of lock him
up, break out
[inaudible]
here's another part of the stadium also chanting,
lock him up.
[inaudible]. So
this is not in and of itself the most important
story, but it's a really important story to
understand the propaganda cycle. This is the
continuation of the propaganda cycle. Trump
goes to the game. Nobody wants him there.
They boo him, they chant, lock them up, and
Trump clearly notices. I mean, it's obvious
that he notices. Then people say booing. I
don't know. I saw the video this morning on
Fox and friends. I didn't see any booing.
Anyone's saying that there was booing must
be spreading fake news. What terrible people.
Donald Trump is right about all the problems
with fake news out there. And meanwhile you
have Fox and friends cutting out the booing,
calling it mixed reaction Trumpist enclaves
on the internet. Say it was liberals who digitally
added the booing that wasn't really there
and the cycle just continues and perpetuates
itself. People were joking when this happened
that this is exactly the way it would go.
And it went exactly this way. Fox cuts out
the booing and calls it mixed reaction. While
Trump is spread. Conspiracy theories that
the booing was digitally inserted by evil
fake news liberals. How stupid does Fox news
think that their audience actually maybe that
maybe that is not the right question to be
asking. In any case, we have a problem here,
the self perpetuating propaganda cycle. I
realized I was going in a direction that maybe
is not the right direction to go in. We need
to understand it but we also need some way
of fighting it and unfortunately the symbiotic
relationship between Donald Trump's talking
points and the unflinching followers that
believe anything he says as if it were gospel
combined with Fox news and the right wing
media that helped to foment and expand and
signal boost these lies and disgusting deprave
talking points makes it really difficult to
fight against this stuff and this is one of
the things that is being pointed out by people
who were following Watergate when it was going
on and are following what is going on right
now. That is one of the primary differences
between Nixon in the 70s and Trump right now,
which is that they both seem to have done
impeachable things. They both are tampering
with witnesses. They both are doing all of
the same stuff. But Nixon didn't have something
like Fox news and the right wing media cycle
and circus, which Donald Trump has to his
benefit, and that may ultimately be the difference
maker in preventing public opinion
from completely turning against Donald Trump.
We will see, make sure you're following the
David Pakman photo on Instagram at David Pakman
show and follow me on Instagram at David dot
package